Hello,
I'm Zina Bodnar.
We welcome to the concert hall in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel prize
winners receive their rewards from the
king of Sweden.
This is in recognition of their
outstanding contributions to science and
economics,
which have brought great benefits to
humankind.
And this is the first time that they are
repairing together in discussion on TV
here or Nobel minds and the joint in the
audience by some of their family and
friends as well as students from across
Sweden.
Well,
Nobel laureates ringing applause and
richly deserved.
It's been quite a hectic week I think
for all of you.
Just give me some of your highlights.
Professor Donna Street.
Well,
I'm the one who had the privilege of
sitting beside his majesty,
the King of Sweden for the banquet.
And uh,
it was thrilling for me and he was just
so much fun and we had a great time
having a conversation.
And you talked about girls just want to
have fun in your speech.
So in seems to be the watch word that's
just fun.
Professor moment
highlights,
you know,
last night.
Do you know when we were,
uh,
having your perceptions about the wire
per class and it was really amazing to
see stables and so on.
And uh,
I was,
I had to play you the extra seat next to
a point is a con printers.
That's what big Toya.
Yeah.
And where are the Greek quite
discussions about whatever thing.
So mixing with the royals or highlight
for you,
you don't do many often.
Well,
the same with me.
I had a lots of interesting
conversation,
so I really enjoyed last night.
So it sounds like the bank quit so far
has been the highlight.
Was it for you,
Professor Frances Arnold?
Well,
I have to admit the banquet was really
quite special.
But coming from southern California,
I have to say snow.
It's no the night of the ceremony and it
was just beautiful.
Jim Madison,
for me the most special was when after
the Er king person at the metal I looked
out for my family was sitting in shop.
My wife and son might be tears over
rice.
Oh,
and you go,
oh,
your bounce,
right?
Yeah.
I got all my bowels right.
Quiet,
quiet a procedure yet.
George Smith Miller.
I hate to be a party pooper,
but actually frankly I think the
highlight was the Nobel lecture is the
thing that
will last on,
uh,
as the memories of,
this celebration beacon to fade.
Professor Bill Nordhaus.
The highlight for me was to bring my
grandchildren here,
my grant,
my granddaughters,
and to bring to the banquet.
And then when they were interviewed by
the news that they were asked was it
too long?
And they said no,
it was too short.
Oh Wow.
Cause I quite young aren't they?
And their mother was teaching them how
to sit up,
right?
Yes.
But not that one around,
but all the adults were getting tired
and they would just
beginning to get ribs.
Paul Romer,
all of these parts were wonderful.
I liked getting to know a few people
here in Sweden,
the Alexander who took our pictures when
we were doing the portraits.
It was just fascinating to see how he
did his job.
I also loved getting to know my driver
who was a woman and also a body guard.
And uh,
she's,
she's pretty cool.
She's bad ass
because I mean,
you really are faced it and celebrated,
aren't you?
So driven around in your own personal
limos and so on.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
wouldn't it,
let's start talking about,
um,
why you want some of these prizes and
we're going to start with the economists
and Bill Nordhaus and Paul Romer.
But let's just have a quick look at what
you want to your price book
by studying how nature and knowledge are
affected by markets and economic
behavior.
William northouse and Paul Romer
designed economic models that address
some of today's most fundamental and
pressing issues,
long term sustainable growth in the
global economy and welfare of the
world's population.
Professor northouse has developed tools
that project the economic impacts of
climate change and provide approaches
for Sloan is progress.
Professor Roma has explained how
knowledge and ideas can surface engines
for long term economic growth and why
government policies play a critical role
in fostering technological innovation.
Paul Romer.
So just explain a bit more to us about
the link between innovation and economic
growth.
When people look back on this time,
what are they going to remember?
Uh,
things like,
uh,
the discovery of electric light,
antibiotics,
uh,
the transistor,
maybe,
maybe cancer immunotherapy that could be
as big as antibiotics in the long run.
Those kinds of innovations just make all
the difference in the quality of life.
But do they actually boost economic
growth?
They do.
And you know,
we get,
we get income,
but we also get quality of life that
isn't always measured in income.
The thing to remember is that we need as
a society to steer the direction of
innovation.
There's some innovation that we don't
want.
Somebody could find a way to get coal
out of the ground at very low cost.
We don't want that kind of innovation.
What we want is more of a say innovation
that helps reduce the cost of low
carbon,
zero carbon energy.
But you say it's got to be,
so markets
are not enough to ensure that we have
that innovation.
Nope.
The way to think of the market,
it's a market works for us.
It's not the boss,
the,
the word the boss,
but don't forget the things that work
like cities work.
There's a technology for getting
millions of people in a pretty small
area.
So just copy the parts about cities,
intellectual property and all that kind
of thing and people putting up,
you know,
protectionism.
Think of,
think of intellectual property is as we
always give these two handed answers.
On the one hand you could use
intellectual property but on the other
hand you could use science,
you subsidize the research and you,
you give the results away.
You know.
Perfect.
President Truman said he wanted a one
armed economist cause he was so tired of
on the one hand.
But,
but,
but it's still important to remember
that that system of science that we all
participated in is a very good way to
produce discoveries and get them out
into a wide circulation.
Bill Nordhaus I me your research looks
at how the causes and consequences of
climate change and what can be done in
economics to try to tackle climate
change.
I mean,
what does your research tell us about
what's doable that climate change is bad
for the economy and that tackling it is
good for the economy?
Well,
I,
I'll just start with Paul Romer left
off,
uh,
with innovation.
So we often think of innovations and
inventions.
Uh,
in terms of the things my,
my friends who have done,
but let's just say that this was,
uh,
this was in a,
this ballpoint pen was actually historic
innovation in about 50 years ago.
But these are often,
we think of these gadgets so to speak,
or more fundamental ones.
But also there's a whole nother class
which are called institutional
inventions where we invent new
institutions.
And in this field,
I think the most important invention
would be a fiscal system to steer the
economy,
whether it's a tax or another way of
raising the prices of carbon fuels.
This will steer the economy.
But this,
this is the,
actually we think it's obvious,
but actually this was an invention of an
institutional kind that has been made
over the last 60 or 70 years.
So you're an advocate of,
um,
carbon tax,
which just basically makes the use of
fossil fuels dirty fossil fuels more
expensive and incentivizes producers and
people through government policies or
subsidies or whatever to try and turn to
renewable.
Feels,
but is that really doable in practice?
What what you economists may determine
is desirable is sometimes not
politically expedient,
was it?
Well,
the thing I would emphasize is not the
carbon tax,
but the carbon price that you need to
raise the price of co two emissions and
thereby raise the price of fuels and all
the products that the fuels are embodied
in.
So it isn't just burning the fuels,
but it will be buried in our
electricity,
in our air,
travel,
in our ballpoint pen,
in,
in proportion to the amount,
and it doesn't have to be attacks,
but does your research,
Bill Nordhaus actually show that it
makes economic sense to tackle climate
change?
You can do it and have sustainable
longterm growth.
So in a,
in a broader framework,
what we know is that the way we measure
our output,
which is the gross domestic product,
miss measures it because it doesn't
incorporate the damages that are outside
the Margaret such as health health is
not included.
Whether we die earlier or die young,
whether we're sick or healthy,
that is not included in our economic
measurements.
So we,
when we include that,
then we see we would actually have
higher incomes in this real inclusive,
comprehensive sense if we include
measures that reduce the damages.
It's not just climate change,
it's also particulates from burning
fuels and Satya and poor Roma.
I mean you've worked as a chief
economist of the World Bank advising
governments and institutions and you
come from a political family.
Your father was a former Democratic
governor in the state,
became a scientist.
Politician's job is too hard.
I did this,
I was going to ask you,
I mean,
yeah,
but you economists can say,
look,
it makes sense to do this and to do that
and we need to direct market forces and
so on and so forth as you've been
saying,
but it's not easy for the politicians to
always do what you think is right.
Oh,
I kinda like Churchill's quote about the
United States is just applied to all
humans.
They always do what's right after
exhausting all the alternatives.
So you just have to be a little bit
patient.
But just staying with this idea of,
you know,
what governments can do.
Professor Miller,
you live in Paris now and we've seen the
[inaudible] on the against President
Macron is desire to have these green
fuel taxes,
which he says are in part to try to
combat global warming.
Look at the problem is he's hired,
he's abandoned the idea.
Absolutely.
These guys,
you know,
he's tying Haiti to do something
innovative,
signed to Bush,
a people headed to save.
I mean,
there's no way we are going to,
uh,
to keep this vis a style of living.
You know,
I stand up,
uh,
we have to do something.
We already have to do something and,
and we have to introduce some incentive
to do it.
Uh,
so I think the taxes,
I'm not an economist.
Okay.
But I understand that maybe the tax on
any way to put some pressure on the
people and say,
hey,
you know,
you,
uh,
you have to reduce your consumption.
So how,
how would you recommend that we,
uh,
we avoid the Yellow Jersey movement in
if we raise the,
if the price of,
uh,
of a carbon is raised because it hurts
people?
Well,
I think the first thing is you make it
comprehensive rather than focusing on
fuel.
And that's actually the most politically
insensitive tax in the world is,
is a gasoline tax or
a fuel tax.
You make it comprehensive.
If you make it comprehensive,
it's more like a value added tax.
It,
it gets built into the chain of
production.
And then the other thing is you start at
a low level and you build it up
gradually.
You need not to have the,
only to have the tax,
but do you need to have the
institutions,
you ha you have to have people who can
accept this and realize it's part of our
system is part of the solution.
So I think just hitting people,
trying to do it as a kind of,
um,
a kind of shock therapy is actually
politically the wrong way.
You need to start small,
start comprehensive,
start universally across countries and
build up gradually from there.
If I can jump in,
I think partly starts small big
government programs have an up almost
always start small and get bigger.
The other thing is we need to have the
whole machinery of carbon taxes ready.
We need to talk about it,
but then at some point there'll be some
huge hurricane,
some huge fire or something that becomes
a crisis and then all of a sudden
politicians are going to say,
what are we going to do?
And if we've done all of our homework,
then they'll say,
okay,
well that's it.
Let's do it here.
You
[inaudible] else want to come in on
this?
We'll do the raising the price of these
fuels and materials is critical I think.
But another way to come at the problem
is to invent new technologies and lower
the cost of the alternatives.
So that's where scientists like us can
contribute.
We can invent those and improve on those
technologies and at the same time then
we're joining forces with the
institutions and you create,
that will bring us into chemistry
because I'm Francis Arnold.
You awarded half of the prize part for
finding green solutions to some of the
world's problems,
like climate change and so on.
So let's just see what the chemistry
laureates won their prize for and then
we'll pick that up.
Inspired by the power of evolution,
Francis on audit develops new biological
material in the form of enzymes,
catalysts that accelerate chemical
reactions.
How Barack is currently,
yeah,
being used in the environmentally
friendly manufacturing of
pharmaceuticals and the production of
renewable fuels.
George Smith was studying the biology of
viruses that infect bacteria known as
phages when he conceived a way of
evolving the viruses to generate new
molecules with desirable properties and
essential part of all living organisms.
Greg winter then harness this technique
to create new antibodies,
immune proteins that attack bacteria and
viruses.
The work of George Smith and Greg winter
has successfully been used to combat or
to immune and inflammatory bowel
diseases and metastatic cancer.
So Frances Arnold,
as we saw just the,
your work has led to,
um,
a multitude of potential users and or
what exactly is it being used to
develop,
do you know?
Well,
chemistry of the biological world is,
is amazing.
The biology is the best chemist on the
planet because she knows how to take
abundant renewable resources and convert
them into an array of chemicals and
materials,
some of which we've used for hundreds of
years,
thousands of years.
Imagine if we could use biology to make
most of the things we need,
including fuels or agents that can be
used for crop control.
These things are happening now.
You've made institutions that will make
that possible by having the,
the price reflect the true cost of many
of these products,
but we are inventing the technologies
that will make that possible.
I use evolution to do it.
Evolution has made everything in the
biological world until today and it can
help us move forward.
So I breed molecules like you breed cats
and dogs.
I mean,
give us an idea of what your work could
really open off in terms of its
potential.
Use it with a little work courses of
life.
The do all this chemistry are called
enzymes.
You have them in your laundry
detergents,
you're consumer products.
They make your blue jeans look nice.
Many of the things that you use in your
daily lives are developed with enzymes.
I make them better than what nature did
for human purposes.
So for example,
we,
several students and I started a company
about 15 years ago that makes renewable
jet fuel for airplanes comes from plant
materials,
agricultural waste products or trees for
example,
that you can use then to uh,
take those sugars and make jet fuel.
So biofuels,
biofuels.
That's one of the examples.
And there are many other examples and
also for example,
the production of pharmaceuticals.
You've also that that can be used to
detoxify the process sorts of
applications.
You can replace toxic chemical processes
that use expensive metals,
for example,
that are environmentally hugely
unfriendly to mine.
You can replace all those with clean
biological processes.
I like to say you replace chemists with
bacteria.
You're actually a mechanical engineer on
she by trained me.
Did you always have a very clear vision
of the kinds of path and what you wanted
to achieve?
Well,
in some ways,
yes,
I was always interested in doing
something that would help humans and the
planet.
I think it's a pretty nice planet that
we live on and I'd like to see much of
the natural world as possible be
conserved.
We won't do that if we don't
learn how to make what we need in our
daily lives in a much more efficient
way.
How you did that,
I had to figure that out through a
meandering path,
which eventually brought me to
evolution.
But we know to describe to my students
what a wonderful world we live in.
I used to tell them,
think of the cow as the best chemical
refinery you could ever build and all
like it takes renewable resources that
makes milk,
it builds a new one when it wears out,
you know,
I'd like,
I don't know,
it doesn't get any better than that.
Well and we can,
we can link but that we can make
something like a cow out of just adams.
I mean who'd a thunk or a yeast take
sugar and makes alcohol.
Oh,
milk can alcohol Georgeson it's just
staying with,
with,
with the chemistry prize,
you were studying the biology of viruses
that infect bacteria and worked with
phages phage display.
And so on as we thought.
So just explain a bit more to us.
It's a way of creating a huge amount of
variety of structures and a way of an
investigator choosing a goal and
selecting from that huge,
um,
array of structures,
the few that can meet that goal.
This is evolution up and down.
This is what evolution does.
Uh,
it,
uh,
it doesn't have a goal in mind,
but if we mimic it in laboratory,
we ourselves can have a goal in mind and
no a idea in detail how that goal can be
achieved.
Phage display your work on that which
really allows us to generate human
antibodies was then built upon by Sir
Gregory winter who is not with us in
this discussion.
But he used that and it went quite a way
to helping tackle rheumatoid arthritis
and metastatic cancer.
So,
uh,
you know,
something which has really been remarked
on greatly.
Um,
I wonder if you could just mention that
link third,
Greg mentioned,
um,
libraries of a hundred billion
structures selecting from among those,
the rare ones that will meet,
meet a goal.
So the goal in that case was a
antibodies that would be fully human,
could be used in therapy,
um,
without provoking an immune reaction
against the antibodies themselves
because they come from a foreign source
like a mouse.
So Greg set out to create a library of
human antibodies artificially,
a huge,
huge libraries and s and devise a way of
selecting those that would have a
specificity for a desired target,
uh,
that has therapeutic,
um,
important.
Okay.
Just draw the link to the literature
prize,
which was an award this year.
Borhees has this famous story,
the Library of Babel.
The yes.
Yeah.
I mean what you're describing is really
just like what borhees describes the
walgreens
that in my Nobel lecture,
yes.
This is nearly infinite set of
possibilities and what the phage display
does and,
and to lesser extent what enzyme
evolution does is give you a way to
search through that library that bore
Hayes didn't have right that way to do
it.
But evolution can take us through that
infinite set of possibilities to find
the ones that are useful for life.
And for us,
if you think,
if we keep looking for a vaccine for
malaria,
do you think we'll find it?
Cause we've only explored a few very
small part of the space.
Uh,
well,
um,
maybe you would fund my grant.
You can do,
yeah.
[inaudible] Smith
pure pitch.
Why not?
You're on television.
Well,
I'm retired now,
so I'm not searching for grants,
but,
um,
uh,
yeah,
so it's specifically the approach,
uh,
that I had suggested was a way of
finding many more vaccine candidates.
We didn't depend on 10 or 12,
but perhaps on 200 candidates that would
have a pretty good starting chance of
meeting the goal of a vaccine.
It seems that a vaccine should be
possible.
You've all harness the power of
evolution in your work.
And,
um,
W W we've talked about cancer,
which remarkably,
it's the first time that a Nobel prize
has been awarded for advancements in the
treatment of cancer.
The medicine or physiology laureates
will come to you in a moment.
But let's just look at what you won the
prize for.
James Anderson and Tesco Honjo
discovered how to unleash the body's
immune system to attack cancer cells.
James Alison identified a protein that
acts as a brake on the immune system and
realize that by reversing it,
the system would be able to attack
cancer cells independently.
Task you honcho discovered another
protein which also operates as a brake
on the immune system,
but with a different mechanism.
It's the first time the development of a
cancer treatment has been acknowledged
with a Nobel prize
professor,
Jim Alison.
So did you set about trying to find a
cure for cancer?
No,
not really.
I was trying to understand,
um,
the function of,
of t cells,
which are a product of evolution and
then ultimately that ourselves that go
out throughout your body looking for
things that out and to be there.
And we developed this system,
upsells or way of making receptors on
them.
They can recognize,
nobody knows how many different things.
So she sells her what type of white
blood cells?
White blood cells that the PTAB antigen
receptors on their call the could
record.
Does almost anything that nature throws
at you because they create in your body
or a library such as we've heard about
it.
It consists of probably you have a,
I'm not as big as some of these
libraries.
We've probably got somewhere between 70
to a hundred million different t cells
in your body that can recognize,
you know,
most anything.
So you set about trying to understand
the immune system better.
We found that there was a,
a molecule called CTLA four anyway,
that was the brakes on that system and
it what a large part of what it does.
It stop t cells from pluff rating.
And one of the ideas that I had was for
some other,
I just,
after we figured that out,
was it maybe the reason that immune
system isn't so good at attacking
cancers because of that,
it stops the t cells before you have
enough to kill all the tumor cells.
And so if we just disabled the brakes
for a time,
we could let them keep going until they
eliminated all the cancer cells.
And so that was the idea.
I'm pretty far fetched because at the
time everybody thought that t cells
divide and they die.
They stop that this is an active
mechanism whose job tells us he chose to
stop it.
So that was your work,
but what about you professor Tesco,
Han Jo,
I mean you were working independently
and also discovered how to kind of
release the brake,
um,
in the immune system,
which stops it from attacking cancer
cells.
But did you set about trying to just
understand how the immune system works
better or did you think to yourself some
treatment for cancer would be a really
good ambition?
Well,
in a bottom my heart because I'm a
medical doctors or originary,
I wanted to have some hope to cure the
cancer or any diseases,
but the,
when I started working in the pd one,
it was just molecule.
We acts ten three identified sterling,
the a t cell,
a selection or regulation or that Tisa
oh gang.
But the one we found,
this is a different break than the Jim
just mentioned.
And uh,
why immune system is working so well
against the cancer because cancer just
accumulate mutations.
They become different from the hour 40.
So that's what reason why we can attack
professor hundred I mean there are
hundreds of types of different cancers.
Yes.
So when we talk about treating cancer or
curing cancer can,
can we actually cure cancer and can we
queue all sorts of cancers or are we
just talking about some specific ones?
Well at this moment there are civil
counsel,
which we can cure a some which are very
difficult.
There are several reasons.
Uh,
one is the immune system cannot approach
to the site where the tumor is located.
Or some cancers do not express so many
different molecule with them.
Normal cells mean the mutation rate is
low.
So at this stage we cannot say we
conquer the cancer to just beginning of
the whole story.
So we need the lots of research.
Professor Jim Allison,
I know that you personally have had a
lot of experience with cancer.
You yourself have had three types,
can't see you lost your mother at the
age of 10 to cancer at brother,
uncles,
cousin.
And so it's,
it's something that you,
you know,
have experienced firsthand.
But I want to bring in one of your
patients who were suffering from
melanoma.
Sharon Belvin,
who's traveled all the way to Sweden to
be with you at the celebrations of the
Nobel prize.
And I'm Sharon Belvin.
I want to eat.
So it give us your story cause you been
suffering from or you had cancer.
What,
what happened?
So I was 22 just out of Grad school and
I found out that I had stage four
melanoma.
So lungs,
lymph nodes and brain.
Pretty much as a,
I was a child.
I didn't even know what life was like at
that time.
Um,
every single conventional therapy for
melanoma,
like doctor Alison said,
I mean,
not very effective.
It was a death sentence at the time.
We tried it all,
um,
until I was offered a clinical trial for
an immunotherapy and it worked.
Textbook,
I got one round of treatment and I had
been in remission ever since.
I was diagnosed in 2004 in remission
since 2006,
[inaudible]
that must be very important to you that
yeah.
Yeah.
It was weird at first.
Um,
that happened in the,
told me that tumor free and I,
I dunno,
I cried a lot along with her along with
her.
And,
uh,
that was 14 years ago.
Well,
let's turn to the physics prize because
that's also had some medical
applications and a professor Don
Strickland and Sherif and the WHO along
with Arthur Ashkan who couldn't be with
us.
And he is in fact the oldest Nobel prize
recipient at 96 by some measure.
We'll talk in a moment,
but let's just,
um,
look at what you won the prize for
[inaudible] and Donna Strickland pave
the way for the highest intensity laser
beams ever created.
Their optical pulse technique is now
used in millions of corrective eye
surgeries every year.
And in many of the industrial and
medical applications off the Ashkin
created optical tweezers,
precision tools that enables scientists
to grab tiny living cells in laser beams
without harming them.
His work has transformed the way
researchers are able to study
microscopic life.
So Donna's strickland along with your
supervisor,
Shit,
nothing wrong.
She's telling the tables,
maybe,
um,
you,
you one half of the price dot ostrich.
And you said you saw your first laser at
the age of 10 and it was love at first
sight and there were many societal
applications for your work,
but you're a great advocate of science
for science sake,
aren't you?
Why?
That's right.
I mean there are now applications of
what Gerard and I did,
but at the time we were trying to do
pretty basic atomic physics with our
laser.
And we also knew that when we changed
the laser,
a intensity by orders of magnitude,
it would change how light interacts with
matter and,
but we couldn't exactly tell how it will
change.
But we knew that it had to change
because we were going to be beating
those atoms to death.
So,
um,
but,
and then down the road,
that leads to discovery and innovation.
But my big thing is that we have to
remember to always try to push for
fundamental science because without
that,
20 years down the road,
there can't be more innovations if we
don't keep trying to understand the
world up to a very small level.
Do you would agree with that or is the
most useful science?
The best science.
I'll see if I can buddy.
And I think you said in my case it okay
from basic science to,
I'm trying to understand how t cells
work.
I think if somebody had just said,
how are we going to kill too much?
There's,
they would have found another way of
pushing on him,
but they wouldn't have discovered that
there's a part,
it's part of the take the brakes off and
then they'll,
they'll do their job.
I didn't take a slightly different view.
It's kind of like this notion of
diversity.
I think you need a lot of different
kinds of activities,
some of which are very problem focused,
some of which are very basics basic.
One of the things we say is that,
uh,
thermodynamics did I,
sorry,
if a steam engine did more for
thermodynamics then thermo dynamics did
for the steam engine.
So sometimes it's not the basic science
that comes first.
If you go to view on this science for
science sake or the best science is the
most useful.
Uh,
no,
I,
I
absolutely not,
I don't believe that the best,
the best science is the most useful.
I mean,
I,
uh,
I would analogize,
um,
innovation,
uh,
to the phages that I work with,
which infect promiscuously and the,
the,
the cells that they,
um,
that they,
that they effect,
in fact,
uh,
they can recombine with each other,
make new versions that go on to infect.
And I think ideas,
uh,
intellectual progress is like that as
well.
The applied science steals from the
basic science.
All the tools that we use in applied
science to solve a problem were
developed by basic scientists so that
you cannot have one without the other.
And basic science goes backs and you use
the new tools that come along.
So it's a back,
back,
back and forth.
And it's not always the basic becomes
hers.
I mean,
I remember the steam engine,
so I think I know said it goes back and
forth,
but some donor said,
I'm going to create $100 million prize
to come up with a vaccine that's
effective against malaria.
Would that be a bad thing?
I mean you all talking about life
science and this is where I think we
differ because for me,
from a life life science,
he's not very fundamental science
steam engine.
We did $100 million
to develop a vaccine for blurry.
You get a vaccine for malaria maybe,
but you won't learn anything about how
to treat cancer.
You'll not true.
That's not true.
When pastor was trying to solve the
problem of just how do you carry food
for the French army that doesn't spoil,
he invents microbiology.
Evolution is a great example.
No one knows how to design an enzyme,
but evolution finds the solutions and
then we reverse engineer the solutions
that work in order to understand the
basic principles.
So in that example,
you're exactly right.
It's going to be a diverse,
we are in a very primitive stage,
so we don't know where the uh,
bill goodies,
you know,
if you know which direction you go,
you get something great.
If that happens,
it's great.
But at this stage I think all we have to
do is dig many places and somebody get
the goals.
Somebody hit something.
And then I have to think,
I just want to reemphasize this in these
points in terms of science policy,
cause often the other people who paid
ours as far as science ask us to do
applied science.
They say what is the application?
What is the use of this?
And if you're doing something that isn't
obviously useful,
then it's more difficult.
It's not just an individual project but
don't have in terms of this whole
streams there we need streams and
different areas.
And there's this,
there's this story that may or may not
be true,
but when Queen Victoria visited fair day
in the laboratory and said to him,
uh,
what is the use of electricity and which
is like a stunning,
stunning question.
And he said,
madam,
someday you will tax it.
Which,
which may or may not be true.
[inaudible] how difficult it is.
4:00
AM fundamentally difficult.
As all of you been saying to forecast
what direction the science,
what we were talking there,
Michael Faraday,
the British scientist in the 19th
century.
Donna,
I think the point I was trying to is
that if somebody came to me and said
what we need is a better tool to cut an
eyeball back in 1985 until we understood
that the work that we did actually
change how we understand that the Adam
and the light sees each other,
we would have always stayed a thermal
process cause it was the only way we
understood it and now it's not a thermal
process.
And so this is,
you can ask for someone to have a
cutting tool but we couldn't have come
up with it from being asked to do it.
At least this would not have been the
where do you have one by accident and
maybe relate the story cause laser eye
surgery,
which was cited in your prize has been
one of the benefits along with them.
How to tackle um,
space debris as well as nuclear waste
reducing its radioactive properties by
hundreds of thousands of years.
But it came about my accident.
And that was in Gerard's love though,
was not mine.
Exactly what we,
what we,
uh,
we are talking about,
yes we will doing fundamental science,
but he's trying to understand the
interaction [inaudible] light if matter.
Okay.
Which is very complicated things.
And,
and when my students,
you know,
uh,
alignings are laser,
I've got the laser in his is,
we took it,
you know,
to the,
uh,
to the ophthalmologists,
look at the look at,
uh,
the students,
and the,
I was just tonight.
And then you say,
wow,
you got heat with the laser and did,
but what kind of lazy or do you have?
And the students said,
you know,
uh,
why are asking me these questions and
say,
well,
because you damage is perfect and now
you have millions of people each year,
you know,
getting,
uh,
I fixed by the femtosecond laser.
So Don Strickland,
in the end,
your approach to pure fundamental
science was actually very useful.
Yeah.
Yes.
But it took 10.
It's a 10 year gap there.
That's a,
that's what I'm saying is that you can't
necessarily hope first of an application
right away.
And I'm not saying that I don't agree
with you.
You can come at it from all sides and
you have to have everybody working on
all levels of it.
Yeah.
But sometimes I get a little frustrated
that the science that just doesn't have
an absolute application seeing down the
road does not ever get the million
dollar funding and baby or it'd be nice
if people would just sometimes say,
I have $1 million for you to do whatever
the heck you might want to do.
[inaudible]
don't a switch.
And it's been much remarked upon that
your the third one,
the third ever female physicist to win
the Nobel Prize and the first in 55
years.
And you have talked about an implicit
bias against female scientists,
scientists,
you were told,
won't you when you were interested in
science and math,
these are boys subjects.
I was told by a high school teacher that
at some point and I was stunned and I
thought that was such a ridiculous thing
to say that.
And I couldn't say that to a teacher.
So I turned to my friend who was a male
and said,
do you know you're into girls subjects?
Because he was so good at English
starting at,
I think most institutions to understand
and be taught about implicit bias and
the fact that you might not think you're
prejudice scans one type of thing or
another,
but that somehow your background ideas
coming into play and that you have to
learn to get around that.
And so I think with effort,
uh,
things keep changing and I'm sure it
won't be another 55
pharmacists on,
I mean wonder if you would want to
comment on this.
The fact is,
if you just look at overall 95% of all
Nobel prices since it was started in
1901 have been won by men.
Is that because,
do you think the women are doing the
work and not being recognized or they're
just not being encouraged in sufficient
numbers to go into sciences?
Well,
in the past,
of course the,
the numbers were very low and that,
that is certainly reflected in the
dearth of women.
Women winning Nobel prizes.
But I agree with Donna that's going to
change and it's going to change fast
because women are doing science at the
highest levels and they make up 50% of
the most brilliant minds.
So,
and they're doing science now.
So I'm,
I'm looking forward to a much better
future professor Mobley actually your
supervisor,
not only was your student a female then
shares the prize with you,
but you a supervisor.
It was,
yes,
I did.
At that time.
I didn't think anything wrong about it
though.
We are the body because that may be
because of French.
Uh,
I think we have historically,
uh,
you know,
always accepted woman.
I mean you see Mary [inaudible] for
instance.
No ice.
Exactly.
And usually,
you know,
when we were going to a meeting to
conference,
you were saying you were seeing
scientist and often,
often,
often you know,
it was,
she was a French,
you know,
if you saw a woman first,
yes.
In our field they were French.
But it's changing fast and part because
of the biological sciences,
at least over half the students now are,
are women.
I think in the,
in the magical horse field,
certainly doctors,
it's Harvard or even more than worry
about why men don't do it.
Well,
come to the end of this discussion,
just want to ask you all and you've
reached what some regard is,
the ultimate accolade receiving a Nobel
prize.
Um,
what next
George Smith?
Uh,
well I'm retired so I bought long since
a thought of what next.
I took a couple of months,
um,
retirement from my retirement just now.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
I guess,
first one thing that's next is I have to
learn that I don't know everything the
way a Nobel prize laureates are
encouraged to think of,
but,
um,
my future is,
uh,
really not specifically in science,
but maybe in political activity.
I said,
well,
for me,
I don't think anything is going to
change because,
uh,
what I like is I science and so it's not
because I get his Nobel prize,
but I'm going to change my habits.
I think on the contrary,
I think I'm going to do it better
because now of course,
you know,
when,
uh,
someone with another advisor speaks,
people listen,
you know,
and,
uh,
so I'm,
I'm going try to do the same thing but
better.
Don't know what else,
what next?
Uh,
well I'll,
I'll continue to work on the things I've
worked on recently,
um,
which are,
climate change.
But actually I began working in much the
same area.
Paul Romer did his work,
which was on technology and technology
has brought,
has been miracles.
I mean we're living here rather than in
caves because of technology,
but just as economic growth has side
effects that dark side effects like
climate change.
I also think technology has dark sides
and I particularly am concerned about
its dark side on our institutions,
on our democracies.
And I'm particularly concerned about the
role of social media,
like facebook on a,
on our institutions.
Well,
I think we've shown now that we could
cure some patients with cancer.
I have the goal of trying to get that
right.
It's close to a hundred percent.
I possibly can.
And,
and,
um,
as many different kinds of cancers
rehab.
And I'm hoping it to the prize again
when I'll give me out a bit of a soapbox
first.
It's shown that immunotherapy works,
which everybody was skeptical.
We're up at four and hopefully they'll
help bring more funding and help us get
the work done,
but also to other things that may not be
so obvious when I missed to,
uh,
let patients have hope that they're,
you know,
death through the diagnosis of cancer
isn't necessarily a death sentence and
you know,
they could actually,
some at least can be,
can be cured and the sec and the final
one is did I think,
I hope that uh,
the pros will inspire more patients to
participate in clinical trials,
which will help us progress faster.
Professor task you Andrea.
Yeah.
Uh,
so I know actually to doings one is to
get the Nobel prize,
but the other one is the age shoot
in my golf game.
Beautiful.
Oh,
well after this week,
I have to say my immediate goal is to
get some sleep.
But I'm very excited about the future of
evolution and how I have one good idea
in the 1980s.
And I've worked at ever since.
But there is such amazing things that we
can use to move into the future.
And the combination with machine
learning and artificial intelligence is
a frontier that I'm going to ride to the
next level.
Don't have strickland.
Well,
I mean,
I have to say that my life has been
turned upside down because of a Nobel
prize and everybody wants to hear from a
Nobel price.
So I'm already booking into 2020 at this
point.
But I agree with George that some,
some of the people that actually want to
hear from you all of a sudden are the
politicians.
And I do have some public policy work
that is not about my own research,
but about photonix in general and how
important it is.
And A,
I'm getting that opportunity to speak to
government leaders and,
and uh,
try to explain that.
And in particular,
uh,
we think photonix has a huge role to
play in environmental measurement and
monitoring.
So we can try to do all these things for
clever control,
but we have to know that we've done
them.
And so we think photonix has a huge role
for that.
And so that's one of the things that I'm
out there pushing in public policy and
poor Roman,
we get to bring 14 people to the events
here at the Nobel,
the ceremony and I brought along
Professor Caroline Webber and her
parents and my family and we got married
this week while we were here in install.
Looking forward,
I'm looking forward,
do a honeymoon where we can turn off the
phones,
turn off the devices.
Just just read
on that joyous note.
Double congratulations to you,
Paul Romer renewed.
Congratulations to all of you that saw
from this year's Nobel mine's.
Thank you very much indeed to all the
Nobel laureates,
to our audience.
And of course to you wherever you're
watching in the wild for me is Dana
[inaudible] and the rest of the Nobel
and mind steam from the concert hall
here in Stockholm,
Sweden.
Goodbye.